a California man is due in court later
today in connection with disturbing
videos that appear to show him pointing
guns out a hotel window police arrested
Stephen hamachi after they were tipped
off about several YouTube videos they
show a man holding several guns and
aiming at targets in downtown San Diego
emoji spoke exclusively to our San Diego
affiliate KF MB from jail Janet shamlian
is outside the hotel where the videos
were made Jenna what kena what kind of
vantage point did homo kee actually have
Anthony he had a clear view of a busy
street this is the hotel police say homo
kee was staying in it is in the heart of
downtown San Diego a place that during
the day is packed with people do you do
this
the videos are chilling and graphic in
them police say a man they identify as
30-year old Steven homo key looks like
he's practicing for a mass shooting
first gathering ammunition off the floor
then loading a handgun and pointing it
out the window as people can be seen on
the sidewalk below talking to himself as
he picks up several assault weapons at
one point we hear a click as he pulls
the trigger of an apparently empty gun
pointing outside the hotel suite he
grabs a bottle of liquor before aiming
at the head of a mannequin perched on a
couch
music police say they were tipped to the
videos last week but they were
originally posted in September when we
received a tip within 48 hours that's
when and that identification of the
suspect was made and an arrest was made
hih mochi was arrested Thursday at his
home in a San Diego suburb where police
seized multiple firearms he posted the
videos to YouTube under another name and
wrote under one he was satire and not to
be taken seriously our San Diego
affiliate KF MB and talked to her mochi
in jail this weekend
the videos are eerily reminiscent of the
2017 shooting in Las Vegas where a
gunman firing from a hotel room killed
59 people and injured hundreds this
video is very similar to that you've got
an individual manipulating weapons in a
hotel room that overlooks downtown San
Diego so that is very concerning
Kaimuki says violence was never his
intent still police credit the tipster
with warding off potential tragedy this
is a perfect example of the community
coming forward letting law enforcement
know what's going on so that we can take
immediate action emoji faces three
felony weapons charges formal charges
will be announced in court this
afternoon from that jailhouse interview
he said he never intended to make those
YouTube videos public we reached out to
YouTube's parent Google for guidelines
on what that type of video but did not
hear back but Tony when you see where
this hotel is located just steps from
the federal courthouse it is disturbing
to think what could have happened
yet chillin is the word Janet thank you
very much yes thank you very much
tipster and even though he explains it
as an art project it does make you
wonder what I've seen maybe needs to
rethink that and if he was planning harm
he's not going to say you're always
planning to to shoot people it's very
very very upsetting it is concerning
that this was actually first posted back
in September so it was out there for a
couple of months